PROFESSOR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
So today we're going to take
a look at solving differential
equations using the
Laplace transforms,
and the problem we're going to
take a look at is a simple ODE,
x-dot plus 2x equals
3 delta of t plus 5,
as a forcing on the
right hand side.
We're going to look at having
rest initial conditions,
x of 0 minus is
equal to 0, and we're
asked to use Laplace transforms
to solve this initial value
problem.
For part B, we're asked
to have the initial value
problem without any
delta function forcing
on the right-hand side to give
an equivalent initial value
problem without a delta function
forcing on the right-hand side,
but yields the same
solution as in part A.
And then in question
two, we're asked
to solve the
second-order differential
equation, x-dot-dot
plus 9x equals u of t
with rest initial conditions,
so x of 0 minus is 0,
x-dot of 0 minus is also 0.
So I'll let you work
on this problem,
and I'll be back in a moment.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
OK, so for part
A, the first step
is to Laplace transform
both sides of the equation.
So we take the Laplace
transform of x-dot plus 2x,
and that's going to be equal
to the Laplace transform of 3
delta of t plus 5.
And we can use the distribution
properties of the Laplace
transform, so this is going to
be Laplace transform of x-dot
plus 2 times the
Laplace transform of x.
On the right-hand side, we have
3 times the Laplace transform
of the delta function plus 5
times the Laplace transform
of 1.
Now, we can replace the
Laplace transform of x-dot
if we use the identity with
s times the Laplace transform
of x minus x at 0 minus.
And we're told that x
of 0 minus in this case
is just 0, so this
term's going to vanish.
And just for brevity,
I'm going to write X of s
as the Laplace transform of x.
So we now have s
times X of s plus 2 X
of s equals, and on
the right-hand side,
we have three times
the Laplace transform
of the delta function.
Laplace transform of the
delta function is just 1,
so we have 3 plus 5, and
the Laplace transform of 1
is just 1 over s.
So I can now factor
the left-hand side,
and I get X of s times s plus
2 equals 3 plus 5 over s.
And note how, when we
have X of s multiplied
by some polynomial
in s, this is always
going to be the
characteristic polynomial.
So if we look back, s plus 2 is
the characteristic polynomial
of x-dot plus 2x.
So this yields 3 divided by s
plus 2, on the right-hand side,
plus 5 divided by
s times s plus 2.
And for the second piece,
we can use partial fractions
to decompose it
into a term times s
and a term times s plus 2.
And when we do that, we end up
getting 5/2 1 over s minus 1
over s plus 2.
So I can combine the 3 divided
by s plus 2 with the minus 5/2
divided by s plus
2 into one term.
So this gives you 1/2 1 over s
plus 2, and we also have 5/2 1
over s.
And now we just take the
inverse Laplace transform
of both sides.
So on the left-hand side, we
recover x of t, so we get 1/2 e
to the minus 2t plus 5/2.
The inverse Laplace
transform of 1/s is just 1.
So we end up with x of t is
1/2 e to minus 2t plus 5/2,
and this solution is
valid for t bigger than 0.
Sometimes, people write
it as this quantity
multiplied by step function.
And x of t is also 0 for t
less than 0, for example.
And it's just useful to quickly
sketch what x of t looks like,
so it's an exponential
decay for t bigger than 0,
and it's flat for t less than 0.
So here's our x of t.
So for part B, now, we're asked
to find a differential equation
and new initial conditions that
reproduce the solution offered
t bigger than 0.
So note how we'd be looking
for a new solution, x of t,
which would be an
exponential decay.
And essentially, we
just grow, so we're
looking at initial
conditions, which start at 0.
If I were to write the original
differential equation-- so this
is the original differential
equation from part
A. Looks like this.
And just quickly to note
that x-dot near the origin
is going to be approximately e
times the delta function, which
means in the original
differential equation,
x is going to have a jump
of 3 about the origin.
So the new initial
value problem--
well, we don't want
the delta function
on the right-hand side, so we're
going to solve x-dot plus 2x
is equal to 5.
But what initial
conditions do we need?
Well, we need x of
0 minus to now be 3.
So when we eliminate the 3
delta on the right-hand side,
we have to introduce new initial
conditions so that the solution
agrees for t bigger than 0.
OK, so this concludes part one.
For part two, we're asked
to solve a new differential
equation, x-dot-dot
plus 9x equals u of t,
and we're just going to follow
the same procedure where we
Laplace transform both sides.
So Laplace transforming
the left-hand side gives me
x-dot-dot plus 9x equals the
Laplace transform of u of t.
And again, I can use
the formula which
relates derivatives of x
back to the Laplace transform
of x, and so in this case, the
Laplace transform of x-dot-dot
is going to be s squared times
the Laplace transform of x.
And then I'm going to
have plus a term which
involves x of 0 minus
and a term which
involves x-dot of 0 minus.
And if your initial
conditions were not 0,
you would have to
keep these terms in.
However in our case,
these terms are
both 0 because we deal with
rest initial conditions,
I'm just not going
to write them.
Plus 9 X of s equals-- the
Laplace transform of u of t
is 1/s.
So again, we have X of s s
squared plus 9-- so note again
how this is the same
characteristic polynomial
as in our differential
equation-- is equal to 1/s.
So X of s is 1/s
s squared plus 9,
which we can use
partial fractions, now,
to decompose it into A over s
plus B*s plus C divided by s
squared plus 9.
And if I were to take a look at
my notes, I have, in this case,
A is 1/9, B is negative
1/9, and C is equal to 0,
if you were to work
out these coefficients.
So what this means is X of s
is 1/9 1 over s minus 1/9 1
over s squared plus 9.
And when we invert the Laplace
transform, the inverse of 1/s
is just 1, so x of
t becomes 1 over 9.
Sorry, this should be s up here.
The inverse Laplace
transform of s divided by s
squared plus 9 is
cosine 3, so we end up
with negative 1/9 cosine
of 3t, and again, this
is a solution for
t bigger than 0.
So as soon as we turn on the
input, the function x of t
starts growing
continuously from 1,
and then achieves an
oscillation with period 3.
So just to quickly
recap, in this problem,
we solved several ODEs,
several initial value problem
ODEs using Laplace transforms.
Laplace transforms are
particularly nice because they
convert an ODE into an
algebraic equation, which
we can solve fairly easily.
The drawback is
we sometimes have
to manipulate, using
partial fractions,
the right-hand
side into functions
that we know how to invert using
the Laplace transform inverse.
So I'll just conclude here,
and I'll see you next time.